he wrote because the masses are
notoriously short-sighted and generally
cannot see danger until it's at their
throats
our statesmen are forced to deceive them
into an awareness of their own long-run
interests deception of the people may in
fact become increasingly necessary
unless we're willing to give our leaders
in washington a freer hand and
in 1981 as the united states was
launching a new crusade for freedom
samuel huntington the professor of
government at harvard
said in a private
but published discussion
and interchange you may have to sell
intervention or other military action in
such a way as to create the
misimpression that it is the soviet
union that you're fighting that's what
the united states has been doing ever
since the truman doctrine
the
the basic up problem is this
the idea is that if you have a society
in which the voice of the people is
heard
you got to make sure that that voice
says the right thing
in totalitarian societies it's not a big
problem
you got a club in your hand
and if people don't behave the right way
you hit them with a club or threaten
them with it so it doesn't really matter
much what they think what matters is
what they do
and that you control by force but as the
capacity of the state to control by
force erodes
it's necessary to control what people
think
and in fact i think you find much more
sophisticated concern
for thought control precisely as the
society becomes more free
according to this alternative view the
media do indeed fulfill a societal
purpose but a very different one
their societal purpose is to inculcate
and defend
the economic and social and political
agenda of the privileged groups that
dominate the domestic society
we're privileged to see and hear a
presentation by one of america's
foremost intellectuals noam
as he evaluates the american power
structure and the mass media right now
on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've talked to some people who live in
other countries who have traveled widely
and they say that americans are the most
heavily indoctrinated and propagandized
people
that they have ever encountered in their
travels
well why should this be
if this is the land of the free press
and democracy
one of america's leading intellectuals
noam chomsky
discusses this in his book which he
co-authored
called manufacturing consent
and we're very fortunate to have dr
chomsky to
give us an address on the subject of why
americans are so manipulated and
controlled
and
how far back on our history this goes
dr chomsky is a professor at the
massachusetts institute of technology
specializing in linguistics
the title is particularly the subtitle
manufacturer of consent in a democratic
society is
a bit paradoxical
manufacturer of consent refers to
indoctrination
and indoctrination is inconsistent with
the democratic society so you can't have
manufacture of consent in a democratic
society
there's in fact a standard view on this
matter which does make it inconsistent
the standard view is expressed for
example by supreme court justice powell
when he speaks of what he calls the
societal purpose of the first amendment
enabling the public to assert meaningful
control
over
the political process
that's pretty obvious idea
the idea is that a democracy functions
to the extent that people have
free access to
eye to information and opinion and of
course the opportunity to act on it
well that sounds obvious in fact perhaps
almost total logical
but it's worth bearing in mind that
there is a contrary view in fact a very
well represented contrary view in fact
the country view is probably the
dominant view
among
people who actually have
written and thought about
the nature of modern democracy
and this contrary view can be traced
right back to the origins of modern
democracy in the 17th century english
revolution
as in the case of most revolutions maybe
virtually all that was a
multi-dimensional affair
with
a civil war between the supporters of
the king and the supporters of
parliament but then a big popular
movement was against all of them and
didn't want
and was trying to and had a very
populist radical democratic character to
it and was defeated the democrats were
defeated within about 20 years by 1660
and you read their pamphlets they were
saying that
we've lost the only
question now is whose slaves the poor
shall be
king or parliament
many revolutions have the same
consequence
maybe all so far
until one yet to come
in the course of that struggle there was
a great deal of concern over the fact
that the general population
was gaining the opportunity
and the even the idea of becoming
involved directly and shaping their own
affairs
and that led to
great concerns john locke wrote
that day laborers and tradesmen
the spinsters and dairy maids must be
told what to believe
the greatest part cannot know and
therefore they must believe
one of the contemporary historians a man
named clement walker
wrote at the time that of the deep
concern of the liberal elements we're
talking about now over the fact that
these guys with their little printing
presses putting out pamphlets and you
know agitating in the army and that sort
of thing
were beginning to reveal the mysteries
of government
and he said if they do that
they will make people so curious and
arrogant that they will never find
humility enough to submit to a civil
rule
that has to be stopped
and the same idea comes right up to the
modern period without running through
the american revolution you can find it
and so on in the modern period
you find major thinkers picking up the
same themes for example reinhold niebuhr
who's a
much respected moralist and
political thinker and very very
influential and among modern political
leaders
wrote
that
rationality belongs to the cool
observers
but because of the stupidity of the
average man he follows not reason but
faith
and the naive faith of the proletarian
requires necessary illusion and
emotionally potent over simplifications
which have to be provided by myth makers
to keep the ordinary person on the right
course
walter lippmann who was the dean of
american journalists
wrote about what he called the
manufacture of consent that's where that
phrase comes from and he said that the
manufacture of consent has become a
self-conscious art and a regular organ
of popular government
in a revolution in the practice of
democracy and this he thought was
appropriate because the common interests
very largely elude public opinion
entirely and can be managed only by a
specialized class whose personal
interests reach beyond the locality that
would be
niber's cool observers now that was
right after world war one and the timing
is important during world war one
john dewey's circle of liberal
intellectuals
were extremely impressed
with
in their words and their perception with
having imposed their will upon a
reluctant and indifferent majority
with the aid of propaganda fabrications
about hun atrocities and jingoistic uh
oversimplifications the point was that
as usual the population was pacifistic
and didn't want to go to war any point
in it in fact woodrow wilson won the
1916 election
on the slogan
peace without victory
a mandate which he predictably
interpreted as meaning victory without
peace very quickly
and
with the aid of the intellectuals they
felt at least maybe they were
exaggerating their own contribution that
they had whipped the population into a
war fever
and
american historians also joined
enthusiastically in the cause
they formed the national board for
historical service
the founder of it
said that what was needed was what he
called historical engineering
a method to serve the state by
explaining the issues of the war so that
we might better win it
the wilson administration established
the first official government propaganda
agency
in the united states called the creel
commission commission on public
information which was a straight
propaganda agency to try to
turn this reluctant and indifferent
majority
into a willingness to fight the war and
succumb the jingoistic fanaticism
that's actually a predecessor of a much
more ambitious program developed during
the reagan administration
the reagan's office of latin american
public diplomacy theoretically under the
state department but actually apparently
run by the national security council
that was an illegal operation
as
the congressional general accounting
office later
concluded in a study of it a legal
operation which had the intent of
intimidating critics and controlling
debate and discussion over central
america its goals as they put it were to
demonize the sandinistas
and of course to
build up support for the us client
states the us terror states in the
region now that was exposed during the
iran contra hearings by one of the very
few journalists who actually did some
work on the hearings
did some journalistic work instead of
just
repeating the handouts alfonso charity
of the miami herald exposed this
and when he exposed began expo later
came out a lot more details in
congressional hearings uh when he
exposed it he went to high
administration officials to who asked
him to talk about it and they described
the these propaganda efforts as a
spectacular success
one of them
described the efforts as the kind of
operation that you would carry out in
enemy territory
that's a very evocative phrase and it
expresses the attitude of the reaganite
political leaders and in fact of state
leaders generally towards their own
populations they're an enemy it's the
domestic enemy that you have to control
and marginalize and you want to make
sure that they don't become so curious
and arrogant that they won't find
humility enough to submit to a civil
rule
uh the uh
out of the
creel commission but going back to world
war one there were a number of
consequences one of the members of the
creel commission
was a man who went on to become the
leading figure and sort of patron saint
of the modern public relations industry
edward bernays
he later wrote about what he called the
engineering of consent which he said was
the essence of democracy
uh it's uh
and the public relations industry is
devoted in the words of its own some
major industry that which was devoted to
controlling what they call the public
mind
educating the american people about the
economic facts of life to ensure a
favorable climate for business and a
proper understanding of the common
interests
the public mind
one a t executive observed 80 years ago
the public mind is the only serious
danger facing the company and it's got
to be controlled
edward bernays went on
to carry out such operations as
demonizing the democratic capitalist
government of guatemala working for the
united fruit company when the united
states was planning to overthrow it as
it did in 1954 turning the country into
a trinal house which has remained ever
since
there's also an academic twist to all of
this in fact it's a major theme in the
academic social sciences
going back
at least 50 years or more one of the
most prominent
modern american political scientist
harold laswell who's a leading figure in
communications and such things
he wrote the article on propaganda in
the international encyclopedia of social
sciences which was published in 1933
and in it he says that we should not
succumb to democratic dogmatisms about
men being the best judges of their own
interests
they are not
the best judges are the elites us smart
guys the cool observers
and we must therefore be insured the
means to impose our will
for the common good of course this he
said will require a whole tech new
technique of control largely through
propaganda because of the ignorance and
superstition of the masses
same theme all the way through
the basic up problem is this
the idea is that if you have a society
in which the voice of the people is
heard
you've got to make sure that that voice
says the right thing
in totalitarian societies it's not a big
problem
you got a club in your hand
and if people don't behave the right way
you hit them with a club or threaten
them with it so it doesn't really matter
much what they think what matters is
what they do
and that you control by force but as the
capacity of the state to control by
force erodes
it's necessary to control what people
think and in fact i think you find much
more sophisticated concern
for thought control precisely as the
society becomes more free
i don't think it's surprising that the
sophisticated discussion
things like the public relations
industry and the academic
side of it and you know the journalistic
side and all these kinds of things i've
been sampling
i suspect if one did a comparative study
you'd find that they developed primarily
in relatively free societies ours is a
very free society in the sense that the
state has
by comparative standards very limited
resources to control by force and i
think it's undoubtedly in fact the most
sophisticated in the terms of
in the reliance on techniques of
indoctrination and control
public relations industry in particular
as a
american creation
you'll notice of course the close
similarity to leninist ideology to
bolshevism which also assumes that the
radical intellectuals
are the specialized class the vanguard
they've got to lead the stupid and
ignorant masses to a better society in
fact the two conceptions are very much
alike
i think that's probably one of the
reasons why there's been historically
such an easy transition from one to
another the move from being a leninist
enthusiast to a
you know a passionate supporter of
state capitalism and you know working
for american aims that takes place
overnight
it's been going on for years
it's called the god that failed
transition
and it happens very simply i mean in the
early stages it had some authenticity to
it when people like ignacio cellone and
others were making this transition but
in recent years it's become just a farce
i mean
technique of opportunism
and the transition is very easy i think
because there isn't much of a difference
in ideological change it's just a matter
of where you think power lies
if you think there's going to be a
popular revolution and you can ride that
revolution to state power and then wield
the whip over the masses you're a
leninist enthusiast if you see that
that's not going to happen and power
lies in the state capitalist
institutions which you have to serve as
a manager an ideological manager you do
that but it's basically a very similar
position and in fact uh in the last
century or so since there's been a more
or less
identifiable secular intelligence
i think you find typically that they
fall into one or the other of these two
categories they
associate themselves with one or the
other system of power and hierarchy
and subordination
in fact what i just said is almost a
tautology it's only if you submit to
those systems that you're counted as a
respectable intellectual
for obvious reasons well coming up to
more modern times in the post-second
world war period uh chara you find again
a deep concern over the need to control
and deceive the public to control the
public mind
presidential historian thomas bailey
wrote in 1948
at the time when we were sort of setting
off on a new war the cold war he wrote
because the masses are notoriously
short-sighted and generally cannot see
danger until it's at their throats our
statesmen are forced to deceive them
into an awareness of their own long-run
interests deception of the people may in
fact become increasingly necessary
unless we're willing to give our leaders
in washington a freer hand
and in 1981 as the united states was
launching a new crusade for freedom
samuel huntington the professor of
government at harvard
said in a private
but published discussion
and interchange you may have to sell
intervention or other military action in
such a way as to create the
misimpression but it is the soviet union
that you're fighting that's what the
united states has been doing ever since
the truman doctrine
which is quite accurate and gives a
certain insight into the nature of the
cold war in particular into the nature
of the war against nicaragua which is
what he specifically had in mind
well these concerns over uh controlling
the public mind
tend to rise to the surface particularly
after periods of wars and turmoil like
the 17th century revolution the civil
war or like the first world war when
woodrow wilson launched the major red
scare which is the
major example in modern american history
of all of american history of state
repression that was really large scale
and effective in destroying unions and
destroying independent politics and
eliminating
independent thought and so on and the
same thing happened after world war ii
with the
phenomenon that's mislabeled mccarthyism
it's mislabeled because it was actually
initiated by the liberal democrats in
the late 1940s
mccarthy just came along at the tail end
of it and vulgarized it a little
uh the reason for this is
is that
periods of wars and turmoil have a
tendency to
uh arouse people from apathy and to make
them think and to make them organize
often so that's why you get things like
the red scare and mccarthyism
right after periods of war and turmoil
and the same thing happened after the
vietnam war which had the same effect
after the vietnam war
elites were concerned about what they
called a crisis of democracy in fact one
of the most interesting books on this
topic or one of the most interesting
books on
most of the insightful books i think on
modern
on the modern democratic system is
called the crisis of democracy it's a
study the only book length study
published by the trilateral commission
it's an important group put together by
david rockefeller in 1973
and it represents the more or less
liberal internationalists from the
three major centers of modern capitalism
the united states western europe and
japan hence trilateral and remember this
is the liberals this is the group out of
which jimmy carter and most of his
administration came
the cri what's the crisis of democracy
that they're concerned with in all of
the democratic societies well the crisis
is that
during the 1960s
large groups of people who are normally
passive and apathetic began to try to
enter the political arena to press their
demands
and that's a crisis
which has to be overcome the naive might
call that democracy but that's because
they don't understand the sophisticated
understand that that's a crisis of
democracy
the american
again samuel huntington
wrote in his report that
harry truman had been able to govern the
country with the cooperation of a
relatively small number of wall street
lawyers and bankers in those days there
was no crisis of democracy things were
working just right
but in the 1960s you got all this
turmoil i mean young people and women
and you know the
labor i mean all kinds of weird people
who were supposed to be sitting quietly
in the corners i began to get involved
and caused this crisis i mean the same
crisis that arose in the 17th century
and that repeatedly arises uh when
people begin to try to take advantage of
the
formal opportunities that exist
among the terrible things that were
happening during the 60s causing this
crisis they said was that you had this
group of people who they called
value-oriented intellectuals
people who were concerned with things
like truth and justice and all that sort
of nonsense
and they're opposed to the good guys the
technocratic and policy-oriented
intellectuals they called the commissars
the ones who just do the job you know
but had these value-oriented
intellectuals and they were doing all
sorts of horrible things like
undermine delegitimizing the
institutions that are responsible for
the indoctrination of the young
like schools and universities remember
this is an internal discussion so they
kind of let their hair down their
general proposal at the end of all of
this these lengthy and thoughtful
discussions was that what we need is
more moderation in democracy to mitigate
the excess of democracy and overcome the
crisis
in plain terms what that means is the
public has to be reduced to their proper
state of apathy and obedience and driven
from the public arena if democracy is to
survive in the appropriate sense with
the specialized class you know the cool
observers smart guys
the technocratic and policy-oriented
intellectuals doing our job in the
interests of the people who have real
power
that's the liberal side i won't go into
what the
reactionary side says about the matter
well
to summarize
there is a standard view of democracy
it's the view of justice powell
the public should assert the review that
he expressed at least the the view that
the public ought to assert meaningful
control over the political process and
there's a contrary view the contrary
view is the public's a dangerous enemy
and it has to be controlled for its own
good of course the way you control
children like you don't let a
three-year-old run across the street
the first view
is the rhetorical view
the second view is the view that's
actually held
and you can see that it's actually held
when a crisis of democracy erupts
and the unwashed masses
begin to try to enter into the political
arena and have to be somehow repressed
either by force as in the red scare or
by other means
in order to
overcome the crisis of democracy well
with regard to the the media play a big
role in this and with regard to the
media too there is a standard view uh
the standard view for example is
expressed again by justice powell and
the same discussion when he
claims that it's the crucial role of the
media to affect the societal purpose of
the first amendment that is to
allow the public to assert control of
the political process standard view was
also expressed by judge gerfine in an
important decision
the pentagon papers decision when he
permitted the new york times to publish
the pentagon papers and he said we have
a cantankerous press an obstinate press
a ubiquitous press and it must be
suffered by those in authority in order
to preserve the even greater values of
freedom of expression and the right of
the people to know
that's one view that's the standard view
and given that view we then have a
debate the debate is is over whether
over whether the media have gone too far
in their defiance of authority and their
adversarial stance
now the right wing claims they've gone
too far they're overcome by a liberal
bias we've got to do something about it
the liberals as in the trilateral
commission
all in fact agree
they in the same study they say that the
media threaten government authority by
their adversarial stance and they've got
to be curbed if they can't curb
themselves the government is going to
have to move in to curve curb them
the
executive director of freedom house
leonard sussman
asked whether free institutions must be
a must free institutions be overthrown
by the very freedom they sustain
rhetorical question meaning we got to do
something about
this excess
freedom that the press is using to
attack the government he was writing
about the
a freedom house study of the coverage of
the tet offensive which became a sort of
a classic
uh allegedly showing that
the press
lost the war in vietnam by unfair
criticism of the government during the
tet offensive it's an interesting if
there's no time to talk about it i may
try to get back to it if not maybe get
through the discussion very interesting
study it was total fraud
falsified the data you know the whole
thing was faked when you actually
correct the errors it turns out that the
press that the real charge of freedom
house was that the press although
completely supportive of the government
policy and working completely within the
framework of government propaganda
nevertheless was too pessimistic they
said
they didn't tell you by what standards
it was too pessimistic the obvious
standard is to compare it with say
internal u.s intelligence assessments
which we have thanks to the pentagon
papers and it turns out the press was
more optimistic than u.s intelligence
because they were believing the public
statements and they know about the
private statements
so freedom house's complaint reduces to
the fact that the press
though prop those totally supportive of
the propaganda didn't do it in an upbeat
enough
fashion
i wouldn't have surprised george orwell
that that should be the criticism of the
press produced by an organization called
freedom house
but that's become the uh
that's become the
standard since everyone refers to that
as the study that proves that the press
was too adversarial
well that's the debate
then then the defenders of the press say
no we're not too adverse or maybe we are
too adversarial but
you got to tolerate us even though we're
cantankerous and so on that's
essentially the issue
well outside of that debate
between those who say the press is too
adversarial and must be curbed and those
who say well yes the presses can tanker
isn't impossible but we just have to
suffer that in the interest of freedom
outside the spectrum of that debate
which constitutes virtually the entire
mainstream discussion virtually the
entire discussion but outside the debate
there is another position uh the other
position challenges the factual
assumption that's taken for granted in
the debate
according to this alternative view the
media do indeed fulfill a societal
purpose but a very different one their
societal purpose is to inculcate and
defend
the economic and social and political
agenda of the privileged groups that
dominate the domestic society and they
do this in all sorts of ways they do it
by selection of topics by distribution
of concern by the way they frame issues
by filtering of information
by emphasis and tone by simple
fabrication sometimes but crucially by
the bounding of debate to make sure that
it doesn't go outside a certain limit
the bounding both in the news columns
and in the opinion columns because of
course the news columns themselves
embody all sorts of assumptions and
ideological presuppositions and so on
to the according to this alternative
view
to the extent that there is a liberal
bias
it serves primarily to bound thinkable
thought
that is to instill the unchallengeable
assumptions
which in fact reflect this rather narrow
elite consensus so the liberal bias
performs a real function it says thus
far and no further i'm as far as you can
go
and i go as far
how far i go is still accepting the
basic presuppositions as unchallengeable
now within those bounds there's ample
controversy
and it reflects the tactical divisions
among elites over how to achieve
generally shared aims
but these limits are very rarely
transcended
so the media thus function in accordance
with what my co-author edward herman and
i have called a propaganda model in a
recent book
that's another view
well uh the property propaganda model
has a lot of predictions as a lot of
predictions about how the press is going
to behave but it also has a further
prediction
the further prediction is that no matter
how well confirmed the propaganda model
is it cannot be taken seriously and
therefore must be effectively excluded
from mainstream discussion and that
actually follows from the model itself
the reason is that the model if you
think it through the model
rejects certain principles that are
serviceable to power
that is it falls outside the spectrum
uh defined by the presupposition that
the media are adversarial and
cantankerous perhaps excessively so
now that presupposition is a useful one
it's serviceable to the interests of
established institutions to believe that
what you're reading is actually
criticism if it's in fact support that's
a technique it's a sophisticated
technique of indoctrination
and of course it's very serviceable to
the media themselves it's nice to think
that you're you know
pride yourself on being an independent
and courageous
adversary of power and since those
assumptions are serviceable they're
going to be upheld according to the
propaganda model and no serious
challenge will be permitted
so that prediction indeed is very
readily confirmed the propaganda model
is never taken seriously it can't be
considered notice that the propaganda
model has a rather disconcerting feature
to it
plainly as a matter of logic it's either
valid or invalid
if it's invalid you can dismiss it if
it's valid you must dismiss it because
it's saying the wrong thing so one way
or another it's got to be dismissed
by its very nature
and notice that truth is no defense
it's very much like the traditional
doctrine of seditious libel
uh the doctrine that it's you can't it's
libelous it's a crime
to criticize state authorities
because that undermines power it's a
doctrine that runs up to pretty modern
times
and truth was never a defense against
seditious libel in fact truth simply
heightened the enormous enormity of the
crime of uh calling authority into
disrepute and the same is true here well
of course the basic
the basic
questions are factual
uh are the standard assumptions correct
that is is it true that
the press is
independent cantankerous adversarial
maybe excessively so or are the
assumptions of the propaganda model
correct that's factual question
and that's the main topic but i'm barely
going to be able to get into it
but before though i won't try to really
you know
no hope in a few minutes of providing
real evidence one way or another
let me just talk a little bit about the
way you would deal with this problem
some methodological questions
first notice three comments
one
the propaganda model has a certain prior
plausibility to it
that is if you'd simply accept
uncontroversial free market assumptions
quite uncontroversial assumptions about
how society works you're led almost
automatically to the propaganda model
you can see that pretty simply simply
ask yourself what the media are
now notice here i'm talking about what
some might call the agenda-setting media
the media that set the frame
that others adapt to
and that's pretty narrow group it's
primarily the new york times and the
washington post and the three television
channels and a couple of others it's not
much else
those set the framework that everyone
else pretty well adapts to
within anything like the mainstream so
we're talking about the agenda setting
media and ask yourself what they are
well what they are is
very large corporations
in fact they're integrated with
often owned by even larger conglomerates
now like other businesses they have a
product that they sell to a market the
market is advertisers other businesses
and the product is audiences
the media don't finance themselves on
their audiences in fact the audiences
are usually a loss the more you
subscribe the more the newspaper loses
money and of course the television set
you know they might anything when you
turn it on
they make their money from advertisers
advertising rates go up
if you have a
the right kind of audience incidentally
a relatively privileged audience raises
advertising rates
so what the media are just as an
institution is major corporations
selling relatively privileged audiences
to other businesses
well what would you expect to come out
of such a system you'd expect to come
out something that reflects the
interests of the sellers the buyers and
the product
that wouldn't be very surprising in fact
it would be amazing if it weren't true
quite apart from that there are many
other things pressing in the same
direction there are after all centers of
power in the society
the state you know the corporate sector
and others and they can
impose punishments for things go wrong
and
offer rewards if things go right you
gain by adapting to them it's less
costly
and so on furthermore the top managerial
positions in the
media
editors and columnists and so on uh if
you make it into those positions you're
part of the privileged elite part of the
very top in fact
that's where your associations are and
your perceptions and your friends and
people you play golf with and everything
else and it wouldn't be very surprising
again if you reflected the same
interests
and it goes on if you think through we
discuss this in our book a lot but if
you think through it there are just many
pressures
which lead
immediately to the assumption that the
propaganda model is highly plausible
even without any evidence it's at least
it's got prior plausibility in fact it
would be rather surprising if it weren't
true on uncontroversial assumptions
that's point one
point two is it has a lot of elite
advocacy
that's what i started with pointing out
that it represents a position that
intellectual elites have thought the
media ought to serve and the whole
system of
education and so on ought to serve
that's the position since the 17th
century probably the dominant position
it's necessary to manufacture consent
for the general good because of the
stupidity of the average man and so on
we have to put aside these democratic
dogmatisms
so we have a position that has prior
plausibility and elite advocacy
and a third point is it's generally
accepted by the public
it's very striking that the debate over
the media is determined by the
intellectuals
and they're the most indoctrinated
sector of the society and for them the
only debate is over whether
the media are too adversarial or not but
there are polls you ask the public what
do you think about the media and the
public generally thinks the media are
too conformist
and to subordinate the power in other
words they automatically accept
something like the propaganda model so
here we have three facts a position that
has prior plausibility
elite advocacy and rather general public
support well that doesn't prove that
it's valid of course but it does suggest
that it ought to be part of the
discussion it's not part of the
discussion exactly as the model predicts
now by now turning to the factual matter
there are by now thousands of pages of
documentation detailed close
documentation
on the propaganda model and
it's been tested in just about every
conceivable way subjected to the
harshest tests we can think of i think
by now it's one of the best confirmed
theses of the social sciences
if there's any serious challenge to it
i've never seen it it's generally just
ignored or else caricatured
so what you have is this very well
confirmed thesis not proven
a very well confirmed thesis no serious
challenge to it to my knowledge it has
prior plausibility the model's plausible
and uncontroversial assumptions
advocated by elites generally supported
by the public but it's not part of the
discussion
exactly in accord with its predictions
it's off the agenda
well the next task and the interesting
one would be to look
at
actual details as i say there's plenty
of things you can look at in print
indeed thousands of pages and more
coming out
uh and i'm not gonna i i almost hesitate
to give examples because they're
misleading
any set of examples will be misleading
because i think its predictions are
essentially universally confirmed with
only statistical error so giving
examples is misleading because you might
argue plausibly that the examples are
not properly selected not be a
reasonable response and that's why you
have to look at a range of tests to make
sure they are properly selected like let
the people who think that the media are
adversarial pick their own grounds
that's the harshest test that the model
can face
so let them pick the grounds well
they've picked their grounds things like
the coverage of the tet offensive and so
on and it turns out that everything
you'd go to
that offensive watergate iran contra
hearings you take a look at them which
they show precisely the subservience of
the press to establish power
compare paired historical examples i
mean history doesn't run controlled
experiments but it runs things that are
reasonably close
for example you can find
similar times and similar periods when
uh
you can find atrocities of roughly the
same scale
carried out by official enemies or by
ourselves and our clients
and look at the comparative coverage or
good deeds like elections carried out by
our clients and our enemies and look at
the comparative coverage
all of these tests in fact every other
one i've ever
been able we've ever been able to
concoct
leads to the same conclusion the
propaganda model is quite valid as a
very good first approximation to the way
the media function uh just to give a few
examples and i stress again they're
misleading because they're few
take say the question of freedom of
press
that's a picket because it's obviously a
matter that the press is naturally much
concerned about and in fact
the press has been very much concerned
about freedom of the press in the last
deck let's just keep the last decade
in the last decade there's been plenty
of material in the press about freedom
of the press
mainly in latin america
and
ask your friends to name
one newspaper in latin america that
has raised freedom of press issues
which newspaper in latin america has
been suppressed unfairly by
a state and therefore we have to defend
it
well you know 99 people out of 100 will
name la prensa in nicaragua
and the reason they'll name it is
because there's been massive coverage of
the tribulations of la prensa and
nicaragua
there was a study by in harper's
magazine by francisco goldman a
media analyst who found
that
the new york times alone was giving
like something like five references a
month that's more than one a week to the
tribulations of la prensa in nicaragua
that's probably more coverage than all
freedom of the press issues throughout
the rest of the world combined probably
much more in fact
well that's an interesting choice
we can take a look at it
not only coverage but also
enthusiastic support i mean the for
example in in 1986
in june 1986 there was a interesting
series of events
the world court condemned the united
states for its unlawful use of force and
violation of treaties
in its war against nicaragua and called
upon the united states to desist from
these crimes
congress responded to this by voting 100
million dollars in aid
to increase to accelerate the unlawful
use of force
the reagan administration announced that
this is for real this is a real war
and there was enthusiastic coverage of
that the world court decision was simply
dismissed as an annoying bit of nonsense
uh
either ignored or falsified but anyway
dismissed it's the court that was the
criminal not the united states uh
the
in response to this virtual declaration
of war as the reagan administration
described it the nicaraguan government
suspended la prensa
and that led to virtual hysteria in the
united states the neiman fellows the
journalism fellows at harvard
uh off immediately gave the owner of la
princesa violeta chamorro an award
the washington post had a big editorial
saying she deserves ten awards no
it's a newspaper of valor that was the
head of the
that was the heading the mary kempton
the
left liberal columnist in the new york
review
uh issued a plea to people to provide
funds for la prensa to keep its
equipment going that those funds could
be added to the rather substantial cia
uh subvention to la prince ever since
1979
uh and on and on
uh well
uh what is la prensa
le prince is an interesting newspaper
it's probably unique in history
it's often believed that la prinza is
the newspaper that courageously opposed
the samosa dictatorship and if you read
the press that's what you would believe
well it does have the same name as that
newspaper but that's about where it ends
in
1980
the right after the sandinista
revolution the owners of la prensa
fired the editor
and
80 percent of the staff left with him
because the staff and the editor refused
to support their pro-contra policy
now the editor and the staff formed
another newspaper on the wave of the
audio
and if a newspaper is constituted of its
editor and its staff that's the old la
prensa
if a newspaper is constituted of the
money that's behind it well of course
the new the prince says the old the
princesses decide how to decide now what
a newspaper is is it the staff and the
editor or is it the owners and the
equipment
this you'll never read about but it's a
fact now the new la prensa
uh supports the overthrow of the
government by a foreign power and does
it quite openly and it's funded by the
foreign power
that is trying to overthrow the
government
that's pretty unusual in fact i can't
think of any remote parallel in the
history of the western democracies so
for example during the second world war
england did not permit nazi germany to
put to fund and run a major newspaper in
london
and the united states did not permit
japan say uh to dominate uh you know to
to invest in and run a major newspaper
coming out of new york in fact we don't
have to go that far
england and the united states imposed
harsh censorship
they wouldn't even let tiny little uh
dissident newspapers go through the
mails or appear and so on
there's no power there's no remote
parallel in western history to this as
far as i can see this incidentally is
never mentioned in media commentary well
nevertheless a true civil libertarian
will defend la prensa from harassment
even though this is unique in human
history this fact because if you're a
real civil libertarian uh you think that
the united states should have allowed
japan and germany to dominate the
american media during the second world
war if you're a real civil libertarian
but
we we now ask we're not we now make the
obvious question i mean we ask whether
the
uh you know the great excitement the
virtual hysteria of american
intellectuals over la prensa
is reflects their
libertarian passions or whether it's
because they believe or whether it's
because they're serving power as a
propaganda model predicts that's a fair
question and there's a test there's an
obvious test and we all know how to
apply it it's a test that we apply all
the time when we look at our enemies
so for example suppose you take a look
at the productions of the
east german
uh peace group or the world peace
council which is sort of communist front
organization
you read their publicity there and
you'll see that they have a lot of
criticisms of the united states often
very valid criticisms
in fact their critical discussion of
repression in the united states and in
u.s dependencies not only is often valid
but it's often the kind of thing that's
not reported here
well do we honor them for that
no of course not we regard them with
contempt and the reason is
because we apply a very simple and
obvious test we ask what do they say
about the repression and atrocities for
which they're responsible what do they
say about soviet repression and
atrocities and as soon as we find out
the answer to that question we just
simply dismiss them with contempt
rightly
you begin by talking about your own
responsibility and then sort of you know
on a footnote somewhere you can talk
about the bad things done by other guys
at least if you regard yourself as a
moral agent you know somebody worthy of
minimal respect and attention
we understand that in the case of our
enemies and we might have enough honesty
to apply the same test to ourselves so
let's try it
we can now apply the test we have this
tremendous libertarian passion over la
prensa the first newspaper in history
to be funded by a foreign power calling
for the overthrow of the government
in which it appears in which it's
published and remember this is not a
major power it's not like the united
states which was never under threat
during the second world war this is a
poor third world country which is barely
able to survive the attack of the
superpower
so that we we have that and we can ask
how the same press has reacted
to other examples of repression during
the same period in fact in the same area
well there are test cases so let's try a
few
let's take el salvador right nearby
except the u.s client
there once was an independent press in
el salvador two small newspapers
la cronica and el independiente two
small newspapers they were not supported
by a foreign power trying to overthrow
the government they were not
particularly left-wing
they were independent run by businessmen
they sort of challenged the distribution
of power you know they said maybe we
should have some land reform or
something like that well they're not
around anymore
they're not around because the
government that we arm fund train and
support
senate security forces to destroy them
one newspaper was eliminated by the
simple device of
taking an editor and a photojournalist
who were in a sun salvador
restaurant taking them out security
forces went in took them outside cut
them to pieces with machetes and left
them in a ditch at that point the owner
fled and that took care of one newspaper
the second newspaper took a little
harder took several bombings uh
three assassination attempts on the
editor
finally the army surrounded the premises
with tanks and then broke in and smashed
the place up and destroyed it they had
previously a machine gunning attack had
killed a news boy at that point the
editor fled that took care of the second
newspaper
well that was eight years ago
so we can now ask how much attention did
that receive that's an example of a
violation of freedom of the press a
little more severe than the
harassment of la prensa
well there's an answer to that you can
check the new york times for example it
has never received one word of mention
in the new york times news columns it
has never received one editorial mention
uh in all of these years and the same is
true the other media simply doesn't
matter these are atrocities committed by
our clients
the guys we pay and train to do that
sort of thing
so all of a sudden our concern for
freedom of the press disappears
uh or let's take another u.s client in
fact the major u.s client israel which
receives by far the major usaid
and is again not a small country under
attack by a superpower
well
here here too history has set up some
interesting tests
the same at exactly the same time that
nicaragua suspended la prensa
after
the virtual declaration of war
in violation of the world court
proceedings at the very same time israel
closed down closed down permanently to
jerusalem newspapers
arab newspapers of course closed down
two jerusalem newspapers
on the charge that
the security forces had claimed that
they were supported by a terrorist group
by a hostile group
well that went all the way to the
supreme court the supreme court judged
that that was legitimate because in it
as it explained in its judgment
no state
will ever permit
a business no matter how legitimate it
is that's supported by hostile elements
and although we have freedom of speech
in israel it does not extend to
activities that might threaten the
security of the state
uh well how much cover that's much more
severe than what happened in the la
prinza case so how much coverage did
that get
well actually that did get one mention
in the u.s press uh it was mentioned in
a letter of mine in the boston globe
commenting on the hypocrisy of the
neiman fellows
noticed that the they did not give a
prize to these editors in fact that was
never even reported
after the central america peace accords
la prensa was opened
the week right at the time it was opened
israel closed a nazareth newspaper
that's inside israel closed the nazareth
newspaper permanently on grounds that it
had
it was supported again by hostile
elements the editor again went to
supreme court
uh pleaded that everything that appeared
in the newspaper passed through
censorship that was disregarded on the
grounds that
if the state says it's supported by
hostile elements that's all that's
required you never need any evidence
when the state comes along and says
security reasons the court's just
accepted
they also closed a news office in nablus
on the grounds that the editor who had
already been in who was already in jail
in fact he was in jail for having
alleged without charge without legal
charge on the claim that he had contact
with hostile elements
his wife had been running the newspapers
claimed that she'd maintained those
contacts they closed the press office
well how much coverage did that get in
the u.s press answer as far as i can
find zero
uh in both cases well i could here's to
here's some real controlled experiments
that history was kind enough to set up
for us i picked the week of the
suspension of the prince on the week of
the opening of la prensa i picked a case
in el salvador just to round it off
let's take our other client state
guatemala
and let's come up to more recent times
guatemala
we the united states enthusiastically
supported a vast outbreak of terror and
violence in guatemala in the early 80s
the reaganites were positively
passionate in their enthusiasm for this
maybe a hundred thousand people were
slaughtered something like that
maybe something roughly that
neighborhood however after uh sufficient
massacre had been carried out
they had what's called a democratic
election
and
uh there's supposed to be a democracy in
guatemala that's what they tell us well
one of the during this
period of u.s backed slaughter they
didn't have any censorship
the problems the press were taken care
of simply by murdering journalists
about 50 journalists were murdered
including you know television
journalists right in the middle of
broadcast and so on and for some reason
you didn't need any censorship when that
was going on in fact i was never barely
discussed you find bear mention of it in
the press well after the return of
democracy which we pride ourselves on
one of the editors who had fled and was
living in mexico decided to return
and he opened a small newspaper about a
year ago last february called la epoca
again it wasn't calling for the
overthrow of the government wasn't
supported by a foreign power it was just
a kind of a
left liberal journal small left liberal
journal when he came back to guatemala
there were immediately death threats
from the
death squads which are just adjuncts to
the security forces
warning him that he was either going to
be killed or flee he wasn't allowed to
run that newspaper he nevertheless went
ahead
and the newspaper published a couple of
issues
and
then
in july
15 armed men broke into the offices
firebombed them kidnapped the night
watchmen
and destroyed the premises
the next day the editor brian barrera
held a press conference to which no one
came except some people from the
european press
and said that plainly there's no
possibility for free expression in
guatemala
he then received another death threat
warning him he better get out of the
country he'd be killed
he was taken to the airport by a
european ambassador to make sure that he
could get out alive
and he fled back to mexico well how much
coverage did that get answered zero
nothing in the new york times nothing in
the washington post that's just last
year now it's not that they didn't know
about it
we know perfectly well that they knew
about it
first of all because it was on the
international it was on the wires and so
on and so forth but also because they
themselves referred to it obliquely
later
about a month later there was an article
in the new york times on some cultural
conference in guatemala back in the arts
pages
and the
correspondent who went there had some
remark buried in there about
la epoca the point is just doesn't
matter i mean that's
it's not just harassment and suppression
it's it's you know destruction and
physical discretion and murder but it's
carried out by our clients so it doesn't
matter
well those are the kinds of things you
find when you look
that's the end of this alternative views
but noam chomsky will be back next time
and he'll conclude his speech and take
questions from the audience
we'd like to thank paulikowski and jim
dickerson
who provided us with the tape of the
speech of noam chomsky
as it was recorded in
eau claire wisconsin and also
during the nineteen eighties the reagan
administration is responsible for
roughly two hundred thousand people
slaughtered
and that doesn't mean just killed you
know that means tortured and mutilated
and raped i mean pot style tortured
that's pretty serious business hundreds
of thousands like millions of refugees
large areas of the country destroyed
all of this in an effort to block social
reform the republicans attacked
dukakis as a card-carrying member of the
aclu that's a very interesting phrase
that means an organ card carryings of
course means real really communist you
know that's what that's supposed to
imply so here's an organization that's
committed to defense of the constitution
and according to the republicans
that's communist well you know i think
that characterizes
modern conservatism
it's really a profoundly reactionary
movement which is deeply opposed to the
values that on which the country was
established
i quoted the trilateral commission
view of the educational system namely
it's a system of indoctrination of the
young
and i think that's correct it's a system
of indoctrination of the young
that was the way the liberal elites
regard it and they're more or less
accurate
so the educational system is supposed to
train people to be obedient conformist
not think too much do what you're told
stay passive don't cause any crisis of
democracy don't raise any questions and
so on that's basically what the
what the system is about
noam chomsky concludes his two-part
series analyzing the mass media and
american society
right now on alternative views
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
this will be the concluding section of
our two-part series featuring dr noam
chomsky from massachusetts institute of
technology one of america's foremost
critics of the mass media and american
society
noam chomsky is co-author
of a very good book on the mass media
called manufacturing consent
in this program he will mainly take
questions from the audience
we also will present some information
from the progressive magazine on mass
media distortions
and now here is noam chomsky speaking
from eau claire wisconsin
in political discourse every term has
two meanings you gotta start by
recognizing that so democracy has an
official meaning which is something like
you know the ability of the public to
take part in running their own affairs
or something but it also has a technical
meaning the one that's actually used
something is a democracy if it's run by
the business classes
if if business runs it especially
business elements that are supportive of
u.s interests then it's a democracy if
not it's not a democracy it doesn't
matter nothing else matters virtually
you'll check you'll notice that this
criterion works quite perfectly for
identifying democracy
same is true of the term peace process
it has a dictionary meaning in the
dictionary meaning a peace process is
some kind of process that's
trying to lead towards peace
but it also has a technical meaning
the technical meaning in its technical
meaning it refers to whatever the united
states happens to be advocating at a
particular moment
whatever diplomatic initiatives the
united states is advocating that's the
peace process
notice it follows that
it's a logical impossibility for the
united states to be opposed to the peace
process that's a nice consequence
to prove that the united states is for
peace you don't have to do any laborious
inquiry into the annoying facts because
it's true by definition
since the peace process is whatever the
united states is up to the united
and the us st
are always opposed to peace
because they're not supporting what the
us is up to and by definition that means
they're opposed to peace you'll never
find in the u.s media or for that matter
in u.s scholarship for the most part any
such phrase as the united states is
opposing the peace process or the united
states is trying to block the peace
process you can't find such statements
because they'd be logical contradictions
actually i
made this statement and a talk in
seattle a couple of months ago and there
is a media analysis group in the
graduate school there and a couple weeks
later i got a letter from somebody
saying he was kind of intrigued so he
did a data based study of the new york
times over 10 years and he found i don't
know like 900 references to peace
process and check them all out and in
fact there's not one case where the
united states was opposed to the peace
process it's pretty remarkable because
that was a period when the united states
was trying to undermine
the diplomatic negotiations and
settlement in central america and the
middle east and so on notice it's pretty
remarkable even the most sublime state
you'd expect that it wouldn't always be
in favor of the police peace process
maybe just by error or misunderstanding
but in the case of the united states
it's 100 i suspect it's 100 percent you
might check and see if you can find any
exception and the reason is it's just
true by definition since the priest
processes whatever we do
now there are two major examples of
peace processes in process now one of
them's in the middle east and one's in
central america
there's no time to go through the
details but if you look
you'll notice that in the middle east
the united states has been trying to
block a diplomatic settlement for the pa
of the arab israeli conflict for the
past 20 years and it's still trying to
block it and in this it's virtually
isolated in world opinion that's exactly
what's going on now
if you like i'll give you some details i
have a detailed discussion of it in the
current issue of z magazine if you're
interested
but i think it's quite clear
nevertheless
the discussion is the united states is
trying to advance the peace presses
there's another peace process going on
in central america which is no less
interesting i'll read you from the front
page of the new york times today
the lead story in the new york times
today which i picked up on the airplane
says u.s
envoy urges hondurans to let the
contrast stay
okay let them stay in honduras the track
you come out and then comes a long story
and you turn to the second page the
continuation page and it says on its
face the administration proposal to keep
the contras in place would seem to be
inconsistent with the spirit of the
regional peace agreement
which calls for their relocation but
administration officials say there's no
inconsistency
well that's about as close as you can
come you know on its face it seems to be
inconsistent with the spirit of the
peace agreement well the peace agreement
is quite explicit
the 1987 peace agreement which the
united states has succeeded in
undermining and destroying
says explicitly
that the one indispensable element in
obtaining peace in the region is the end
of any form of support
logistical military propagandistic etc
for irregular forces like the contras
now it's not it doesn't seem to be
inconsistent in with the spirit but it's
flatly inconsistent with the words uh to
keep the contours in place
uh well the same is true of everything
else about that
uh the there was a there's uh that was
the 1987 peace agreement which the
united states tried to undermine and did
undermine with the support of the media
uh but there are others there's a uh
right now there's a debate going on on
so-called humanitarian aid to the
contras
well the term humanitarian aid has a
meaning
in fact the world court and its decision
defines humanitarian aid
it you look up paragraph 243 of the
world court decision and it defines
humanitarian aid as aid given for the
hallowed purposes of the red cross
namely to relieve human suffering
and crucially it says aid that is given
without discrimination to civilians on
all sides of any conflict only under
such conditions that anything qualifies
humanitarian aid well that means all the
stuff given as called humanitarian aid
has nothing to do with humanitarian aid
it's military aid but you'll never find
this discussed in the media i doubt if
you can find one reference to this in
the media so now we're talking about
humanitarian aid that's going to be
voted the bush administration hopes to
keep the countries in place in violation
of the 1987 agreement well there was
also a central american president's
agreement just last month
and that said something too it said the
countries have to be relocated away from
honduras so this is flatly inconsistent
with that not the spirit but the wording
furthermore
there was a cease-fire agreement between
nicaragua and the contras last march
over the deep objections of the united
states last march 23rd and that
cease-fire agreement has some very
specific terms in it
it says that aid can continue to go to
the contras
in
ceasefire zones all of which are
in nicaragua when
provided by a neutral agency that's what
the wording of the agreement says
congress passed legislation right after
that sent to send what they call
humanitarian aid to the contras but if
you look at the legislation it says
specifically that it must be in accord
with the
cease-fire agreement and it must be in
accord with the central american peace
agreement well that means that the only
aid that congress could legally send to
the contras in accordance with its own
legislation
is aid given by a neutral agency like
the red cross
two contras in
ceasefire zones inside nicaragua that's
not just my interpretation the ceasefire
agreement also specified an
international official in charge of
monitoring the agreement the secretary
general of the organization of american
states
he wrote a letter to the president
secretary of state george schultz
stating that the aid that the united
states was sending was inconsistent with
the cease-fire agreement and he was
wanted to call the attention of the
secretary of state to this serious
violation of the ceasefire agreement and
the congressional legislation that was
never reported
uh congress proceeded to send the aid uh
the neutral agency that they selected
was usaid state department subsidiary
that's the u.s that's the neutral agency
and they're sending it illegally to
honduras
in fact the aid that they're sending is
not only incan flatly inconsistent with
the central american peace agreement
it's even inconsistent with congress's
own legislation
that's pretty tricky you'll never find
one word of discussion about this this
is against the background of years of
the united states trying to undermine
every effort at political settlement of
that of those conflicts whether they
were
through the contadora group of latin
american
democracies or the united nations or the
security council where the united states
vetoed resolutions calling on all states
to support international law and so on
and it continues but nevertheless
according to the media the press the
united states government is supporting
the peace process well
i'm suggesting that wherever you look if
you look closely you'll find exactly the
same thing
you'll find
quite a remarkable degree of civility
and subordination established power
uh
particularly remarkable because there's
no force behind the there's no authority
that can impose force this is willing
subservience not compelled subservience
and the kind that in fact flows i think
just from the
logic of the institutions for the
reasons that i mentioned well let me
return finally to a prediction of the
propaganda model that i mentioned
already
namely that however well confirmed it is
uh it cannot be part of the discussion
it's going to got to remain outside the
spectrum of
debate and respectable circles
maybe with some very marginal exceptions
other reasons are the ones i mentioned
they're pretty obvious that conclusion
again is quite well established
empirically and i think we may assume
with fair degree of confidence that that
will continue to be the case
noam chomsky will take questions from
the audience later right now here is
some information from the progressive
magazine
featuring a study by martin lee and
norman solomon from the organization
fairness and accuracy in media
and it's about the categories of
distortion
from information from the establishment
media one category is loaded language
for instance one person one group that
might be struggling for civil rights
will be
just engaged in civil disobedience and
the other end will be labeled as
terrorists
another
example is the new york times said that
moscow was going to violate the u.s
soviet treaty
but when it came to the americans
violating the abm treaty they only said
that the reagan administration was going
to reinterpret
the treaty
also they used left wing and right wing
very interestingly and with a great deal
of of
distortion new york times correspondence
for instance said
in about the municipal elections in
berlin both the extreme left and the
extreme right have gained in this
election
okay who was the extreme right well it
was
the republican citizen party which was
uh very racist and uh
very very right-wing but who was the
left-wing party that he was concerned
about
the greens the little greens you know
the ecology pro peace people and so this
was the this is the way the
new york times distorts things you know
saharto is moderate
and the greens are leftist
and only a few of the nuttiest
reactionaries are right wing whereas one
could argue that george bush is right
wing that nbc is right wing and ge
and most of the corporations are
advocating policies that in an earlier
age would be seen as right wing to the
right of any moderate center that you
can possibly imagine
well whoever is in power always usually
designates themselves at the center and
anything to the either side of it are
badasses
well there's another distortion they of
course they throw around the word
communist all the time
for people they don't want communist or
leftist or marxist even calling the
sanonistas communists in the new york
times and the networks all the time
although they were so far from it it was
incredible number they also talk about
the budding democracy in el salvador
that lovely land of death squads
they
i always took me to death in vietnam
more they say well uh 50 communist
troops were killed and injured today
you never hear them talk about the
how many capitalist troops were killed
or injured we're always the communist
how many counter-revolutionary
interventionist imperialist forces were
shot
another category of distortion in this
article in the progressive is
unattributed assertions and suspicious
resource uh sources
there for instance was dan rather had an
article in which he said bert quint
reports
that
the palestine liberation organization
conference in algiers was orchestrated
by moscow well where did you get that
information nobody said
when they
tried to nail down then rather on it cbs
said well
that might have been a strong word
orchestrated by
moscow might have been ill chosen well
150 million people how many ever saw it
and they didn't make a retraction in
point of fact the networks are
constantly conduits for disinformation
it's not just the cia that plants
stories like gaddafi was going to
assassinate reagan remember that one but
the administration are constantly
feeding lies into the media that then
the media broadcast again using this
cover of unattributed
sources
i found out in the research i'm doing on
this book on u.s television that john
mcquathy who's the abc
defense and pentagon reporter has been a
constant source of disinformation
for years during the reagan
administration there are so many leaks
from the government
so-called leaks you so many of them you
consider plants because just this
information which the government wants
to get into the regular media or they'll
say well us intelligence experts believe
or cia people think but they don't say
who it is and so you can know exactly
who's pumping out this disinformation
let's return to noam chomsky as he takes
questions from the audience the first
one was about his opinion of pbs and the
aclu the aclu is an important
organization
the aclu in fact became the aclu right
at the time of the red scare wilson's
red scare
and in response to that severe
repression and since then it has a
pretty admirable record of conservative
wreck it's a conservative organization
very conservative
the term conservative is another one of
those that's been
distorted out of any relation to its
meaning but in the real sense of the
term conservative the aclu is a
conservative organization
which is trying to preserve basically
conservative values 18th century values
and it does a pretty good job on it it's
had bad periods i went along with
mccarthyism for example and it doesn't
take the really hard cases those are
taken by more militant civil rights
organizations but it has done very good
things
it's very striking fact that about
the political system
you recall what happened with the aclu
in the last elections
the republicans attacked
dukakis as a card-carrying member of the
aclu that's a very interesting phrase
that means an organ card carryings of
course means real really communist you
know that's what that's supposed to
imply so here's an organization that's
committed to defense of the constitution
and according to the republicans
that's communist well you know i think
that characterizes
modern conservatism it's really a
profoundly reactionary movement which is
deeply opposed to the values that on
which the country was established and
that's why they would call a an
organization uh calling for the defense
of the constitution a uh subversive
organization now what was the democrats
defense against this charge
that they were that dukakis supported
the constitution
uh his defense was to deny that he
supported it
i mean he didn't say yeah of course i'm
a member of the aclu and proud of it uh
what he said is what he gave it they
published a list of cases of the aclu
that he disagreed with that was the
democratic response well that tells you
something about elite opinion
i know i don't think the aclu is an
illusion i think it's an important
organization i'm
proud to be a card-carrying member and
to speak at their meetings and stuff i
also think there are more courageous
organizations that take harder cases
what was the second question oh yeah
public broadcasting well public
broadcasting is an interesting case
in a lot of countries
public broadcasting is
i mean how free public broadcasting is
public broadcasting is not subject as
much at least to business and to
corporate and advertiser pressures
however of course it's subject to state
pressures
and uh
how free and independent public
broadcasting is depends typically on how
free the state is
not like in a
free society public broadcasting will be
free for many years the bbc was very
independent with thatcher
another
anti-democratic reactionary
the bbc has been become much more
constrained because
the british government is also imposing
harsh constraints on freedom of
expression under thatcher and others
mislabeled conservative
but
turning to the united states public
broadcasting is very weak
as compared with virtually any other
country any other democratic country you
know any of the you look at the
industrial democratic societies they all
have public broadcasting some of them
are only public broadcasting for example
in israel there's only a state tv
in england until recently there was only
state tv and now there's another channel
two other channels i think in canada if
i
till recently there's only cbc there may
be another one now i've forgotten
but it's common i mean those are major
channels and that's true of most
countries and
how free they are depends on how free
the country is in the united states
they're very weak because here things
are run by corporations this is a
business-run society
and things supposed to be under
corporate control
so public broadcasting is very limited
and in fact it survives to a large
extent on corporate donations which is a
constraint
gulf and western in one famous case
forced
wnet-tv in new york to cancel a program
on hunger
simply by saying they'd remove their
subvention and they had to submit
and public broadcasting is is uh you
know it varies across the country
in the
major centers like boston and washington
and new york
it's very very narrow
it's in fact it's i think it's more
tightly censored than corporate radio
and television
uh in other parts of the country like
you know laramie wyoming and des moines
iowa and maybe here
it's more free
and that makes sense the same is true of
the commercial media
because in the ideological centers it's
much more important to control what
people think
what they think out in the sticks
doesn't matter so much because there
isn't much they can do about it
and as a result
it's more open i mean i can see that
myself if i go to laramie i get
interviewed on public television on
public television but that's
inconceivable virtually inconceivable in
boston
uh you know maybe a minute now and then
or something in the interests of you
know fairness or something but
and the reason is that you know
the main centers like say boston are
subject to what's called a liberal bias
meaning tightly controlled by
ideological managers who know their
business
and don't let things get out of hand
i think it's possible to put the kind of
pressures on public broadcasting that
can't be done on corporate media but to
that that requires organization
and real participation there are other
forms i should say
one of the most some of the most
interesting and important things are
listener supported radio
now that's usually a small scale
operation you know
fly-by-night operation but they're very
important
that's really out of corporate control
or state control and you can tell you
travel around as i do to communities
and the ones that have listener
supported radio are quite different
there's just an independent culture that
can sustain itself there
with people participating and you know
involvement of the community i mean it's
just much more democratic
and that you can see the results
but that's you know very limited
resources because resources lie
essentially in the business community
another
way they distort it is to when they'll
have a government source that has
credibility right the secretary of state
or somebody like that
but then when they have non-government
sources or critics
they'll have somebody from a foreign
government they'll have a russian or
they'll have
ortega from nicaragua but they don't
show
the people in the united states who are
progressive critics of the us government
they always make it looks like it's
those dirty foreigners against the good
old stars and stripes
so this is one way of showing for
instance and when they do have a point
counterpoint they got to the absurd
stage where the mcneil era program they
had a thing on
nuclear weapons issues and who was the
dove they had was old sam nunn giving
the
dovish point of view in fact frank fair
that same group that puts out this
analysis that you're reading has
recently published a report on the
mcneil lair show where over a nine-month
period they documented who the
spokespeople were
from the different groups
of the society on the program and they
documented that it's almost
primarily
conservative groups and spokespeople
it's corporate spokespeople it's these
conservative think tanks that doc the
dominate the special guest in expert
segments and there's almost no labor
union people environmentalists public
interest group people and no one
left the center is ever on there
supposedly i think it was lair jim
lehrer said he doesn't like moaners and
whiners from the left and so he gave his
producers instructions not to bring any
of those types on the
program and they did a case study for
instance of the exxon valdez
story that during the period they were
monitoring the mcneil lair program was
one of the big stories and they didn't
have one environmentalist on despite
many special segments on the show they
would tend to have the governor of
alaska or exxon corporation spokesperson
or a congressperson but they never had
environmentalists on who you would think
would be the experts that could really
assess the impact of the oil spill on
the environment likewise when they have
a segment on central america they rarely
have people from say nicaragua or the el
salvador left they always have these
right-wing
conservative types here in the u.s who
are pontificating about central america
and so you get a very narrow
spectrum of opinion on our public
television program
the first cousin category to what we're
talking about in this progressive
article
category is stenography or
journalism i thought it was very
interesting that the
there was an article in the daily texan
where a
woman who was a journalism major she was
complaining because she said that a
journalism professor told her that her
job is mainly to be a quotation gatherer
well that's apparently what's the what
the news media like because they come up
there and they they take down word for
word all the things these government
officials have to say
even when they're lies they don't check
them out see if they're lies their
statements are not corroborated they
just quote them and put them before you
on the evening news and their little
sound bites but they don't balance this
by getting some of these other people on
that we've been talking about some of
the other
progressives or critics from the
american
left or progressive point of view
another category is kissinger hague
disease it seems that david brinkley and
meet the press face the nation hot and
nightline
they seem to have those two
martians we call them anyway they're
they seem they love the military and all
the bloodshed that they can cause
but they have kissinger and hagon time
and time and time again of course they
don't tell you that kissinger
has his own business which is involved
in a lot of these activities which
they're talking about on the evening
news in fact frank we've given the
report that mother jones has about
what institutes what think tanks in
washington provide the guest experts for
either ted koppel in the public affairs
discussion shows or the pbs shows and
it's almost always the heritage
foundation the american enterprise
institute or other of these right-wing
organizations and think tanks
occasionally you get the brookings
institute which is a very moderate
centrist think tank giving some of its
experts on these programs but you never
have the institute for policy studies or
any of nader's think tanks or any of the
left progressive organizations giving
their spokespeople most of whom have
academic credentials who have written
books who have phds who are college
professors whereas most of the people
that are the sound bite experts from the
american enterprise institute and the
heritage foundation have very minimal
academic credentials many of them don't
have phds many of them have not
published major books but they're taken
as the expert because they know how to
produce the sound bite the 20-second
blurb that the networks are looking for
plus they're safe
if you were the leader of the country
on issues such as central america and
israel
and you were the one that was making the
decisions how would you deal with the
problem in the middle east now if i were
the leader of the country i probably
wouldn't do anything very much different
from anyone else
no matter what i believed and the reason
is i would be under such
tight constraints from real objective
power that i just wouldn't have any
leeway
there's good reasons for it but so let
me instead of going into that i go into
that if you like but instead of doing
that let me answer your first question
let me take your other way of
formulating what do i think we ought to
do
well i think there are some pretty
obvious answers
both in the middle east and in at least
there's a general framework for obvious
answers
in the middle east and in central
america
in the middle east there's been a very
broad international consensus
on a political settlement of the
arab-israeli conflict than there has
been for many many years
that consensus for example was expressed
in a uh
uh
a resolution that came to the u.n
security council in january 1976 that's
13 years ago
uh it called for
a
two-state settlement uh establishment of
a palestinian state and the west bank
and the gaza strip uh a settlement on
the internationally recognized borders
namely the prejudice 1967 borders and
then it just repeated the wording of u.n
242 the main u.n document
with guarantees for the independence and
territorial integrity and security of
every state in the region and its right
to live in peace
and security within recognized
boundaries and then it went on to
discuss some modalities you know for
achieving this end that's the basic
framework of the international consensus
well that particular resolution was
vetoed by the united states
uh israel refused to attend the session
the resolution was initiated by the
three major arab states syria jordan and
egypt the three confrontation states it
was supported by the plo in fact it was
openly supported by the plo according to
the israeli delegate who's now the
president of israel it was in fact
prepared by the plo notice that that
is worth noting this because that means
that already 13 years ago
arafat had gone exactly as far
as he did in that famous press
conference on december 14th which was
alleged by the media to have changed
everything nothing changed he just
repeated the same position he'd been
saying for the last 13 years
there's reasons why the united states
changed its position but that's
different
this was supported by the soviet union
it was supported by most of europe it
was supported by most of the aligned
non-aligned countries in fact virtually
by the entire world
that's why the united states had to veto
it alone
uh
well that's you could argue about
details but something like that is a
probably the only plausible at least
interim settlement
if you wanted to pursue it seriously you
have to talk about economic relations of
a federal nature between the two states
and all sorts of other things and
modalities to secure it and so on and so
forth but that general idea has been a
very broad international consensus for
years the united states is alone
virtually aside from israel and opposing
it i mean not totally alone like it's
posed by gaddafi there are rejectionists
aside from the united states part
there's marginal groups around the world
like khomeini you know the afghan rebels
i mean a few other groups that oppose it
but primarily it's opposed by the united
states that's why it doesn't get
anywhere now that has disappeared from
history
on the assumptions of the propaganda
model that's not part of the peace
process why because the united states
was opposed to it and it's a logical
impossibility that the united states
should be opposed to the peace process
so therefore that's gone from history
when the united when the new york times
or any scholarly
monograph for that matter reviews the
peace process they don't include this
because this is not part of the peace
process well that's only one example
there are many others
and i think that's a general framework
for settlement as far as central america
is concerned
i think it's pretty obvious what ought
to happen generally speaking i mean the
united states has carried out major
crimes in central america really major
crimes uh in the ninth i mean first of
all our whole history look central
america is one of the most miserable
areas of the world
and it's an area where u.s influence has
been enormous for a century
well at once that tells you something
you know i mean not to think very hard
to figure out what that means uh and
it's for reasons there are reasons for
it you look into the details you can
find out reasons for it even the
so-called
constructive programs were actually
lethal like take the alliance for
progress
you know most of our of the a lot of
what happened in central america is just
because we impose dictators and
gangsters and terrorists and so on if
they ever try to get independent as in
guatemala but every once in a while
there's something called a constructive
program the alliance for progress is the
famous case well you know the alliance
for progress was like a plague
probably the worst plague that hit
central america until the reagan
administration that's killers in a
category by themselves
uh the alliance for progress first of
all was a completely cynical operation
i mean the alliance for progress was not
instituted by the kennedy administration
because they suddenly discovered that
there are poor people in central america
and they knew that all along
it was initiated because they were
afraid that the poor people in central
america were going to follow the cuban
model
now that means it began as a purely
cynical operation
okay and that showed
the alliance for progress was designed
to impose on latin america altogether in
fact an agro export model
they're supposed to shift production
from
subsistence crops to
[Music]
export
for the benefit of u.s agribusiness in
the american market
well it has consequences for example it
means that
farmers in central america are expected
not to produce rice and beans for them
people locally to eat but asparagus and
broccoli and flowers for yuppie markets
in the united states
well for one thing that means they don't
have anything to eat so you got to
import food which they import from us
at high costs which is good for american
agriculture
subsidized usually by the american
taxpayer now subsidized by them uh sec
and it also means that and that food is
not going to be equally distributed it's
going to be distributed to the rich
furthermore the production is going to
be by the rich because it takes capital
inputs to produce the fancy fruits for
the american market
so there's going to be landless peasants
furthermore they're going to produce
beef
in fact every latin central american
country beef production moved up rapidly
under the alliance for progress while
beef consumption reduced
and the reason is
that
ranchers moved in often with north
american connections drove peasants off
their land
turned it into grazing lands so they
could send beef to north american
markets for hamburgers
great for agri
terrific for american agribusiness and
for pesticide and fertilizer
manufacturers and for the rich in
central america but not very good for
the people now you take a look at you
look at your favorite economics book or
latin american studies book and they'll
tell you that the alliance for progress
created an economic miracle
well you know from a certain point of
view it did a gross national product
went up all through central america so
did malnutrition
you know uh and the reason is obvious
you drive people off the land up into
the hills
and you take over their land and you
produce beef for export and fancy crops
it's good for the gross national product
just means the people starve
in fact the crisis of the 1980s is
largely caused by that plague well let's
just take the 1980s during the 1980s the
reagan administration is responsible for
roughly 200 000 people slaughtered
and that doesn't mean just killed you
know that means tortured and mutilated
and raped i mean pop style torture
that's pretty serious business hundreds
of thousands like millions of refugees
large areas of the country destroyed
all of this in an effort to block social
reform
in all three major countries where we
were involved in honduras and el
salvador and nicaragua
now that's serious
what should we do well the first first
thing we do is stop torturing them
a second thing we should do is pay
reparations because we owe them
and uh after that maybe there's some
hope that they could reconstruct from
the damage we've done to them
i think that's what we ought to do try
to find anybody suggesting that in the
mainstream however
you can't express this view not because
it's false but because it's true and if
you look into it you'll find that it's
true i think
now what should we do
i mean let's go back well what we should
do i mean we are free to act
plenty of things that we can do
and for one thing we can just provide
aid ourselves you don't have to wait for
the state to order you to provide aid
they need it badly i mean nicaragua
nicaragua's
reeling the hurricane last october was
the final blow
they're going to have mass starvation
there now the government of course
is delighted the us government they
won't send them a penny because they
want them to suffer as much as possible
but american citizens are much more
independent
and in fact they've raised a lot of
money
for example there's one small jesuit
center in
north carolina or virginia or somewhere
the
quest for peace it's called
the quixote center little i think they
may have three staff members or
something they've raised millions of
dollars
from people in the united states who are
able to think for themselves who aren't
just slaves of power
and those are things that can be done
you can help people survive
and you can after all put pressure on
on congress on the media to do something
about this a lot of ways of doing that
ways
all sorts of ways ranging from civil
disobedience to writing letters to the
editor to you know a mass popular
organization you know they're not going
to put you in jail for it
in that sense a very free country which
means if you don't do it you have a lot
more responsibility than if you don't do
it in a place where you are afraid that
you're going to be repressed so there's
no shortage of things to do it's just a
matter of willingness to do them and the
willingness to do them begins with a
willingness to recognize reality
that's the hardest part i think once you
recognize reality you won't have any
more questions about what to do
because it's too obvious
so the first thing to do is to recognize
the reality that takes a little work
but once you recognize it i think it's
obvious what to do
another category in the
article in the progressive is
passive phrases glossed over euphemisms
shows how for instance new york times
said that
salvador allende's policies in
1907
era before the coup in chile allende's
policies caused chaos which brought in
the military
kind of obscuring the fact that there's
a u.s government particularly the cia
and u.s corporations like i t and t
which fomented the chaos in the first
place
and the notion that the chaos prompted
the military of the chilean government
to move in and restore order really was
rather rather downplays and neutralizes
the american role and also the brutality
of the coup in which people later uh
tens of thousands were
jailed tortured disappeared and just
plain killed
well in turkey you know turkey has been
a has had an abysmal
record of
on civil rights they've tortured people
murdered people incarcerated trade
unionists
and
it's it's been horrible in turkey but
the washington post said that
they called these controversial measures
and turkey's military despot pursued a
quote down-to-earth approach
as he sought to deal with the rough and
tumble of everyday politics
rough and tumble murder and torture rev
and tumble
well the miami herald had an article too
that they mentioned in this category
there was it was headlined chemophobia
may be as bad as chemicals saying that
the people who are trying to fight the
chemicals that are in our food
and in the air are really bad because
being afraid of those good chemicals is
really harmful
the woman who wrote it said that
the best scientific estimates which she
didn't specify
say that 99.9 of carcinogens in the diet
come from natural sources
which she didn't identify she said that
synthetic chemicals account for only
0.0
percent of the carcinogens which the
americans consume none of this
none of this
was
had any
identification or source for any of
these assertions there's been quite a
bit of this
talk about so-called chemophobia
and yeah this is the corporations are
pushing this big the other thing that
the big polluters are doing who are
producing chemicals and wastes and
different things that are pesticides
that are poison the environment and our
food they're producing these pbs nature
shows for their patents penance for
their crime
and fair in their latest edition of
extra their newsletter has a list of the
biggest chemical polluters in the world
and their crimes and the penance that is
the pbs
series that they fund so ba ba sf that's
one of europe's most energetic toxic
dumpers
it funds the pbs program adventure
chevron which is california's largest
petrochemical polluter funds the pbs
program national geographic special
dupont the major chemical polluter the
world's largest producer of ozone eating
chemicals produces discoveries
underwater
georgia pacific which is a clear-cut
timber and paper mill polluter produces
forever wild about the environment and
on and on and on through the biggest
polluters their crimes and the whole
series of pbs nature programs that they
produce that very rarely talk about
pollution and some of the problems of
these corporations destroying the
environment so this is the way they buy
protection by controlling the pbs
programs about nature and the wilderness
and making sure that their crimes are
not
investigated
when i graduate i'm going to be a
history teacher history teachers what do
you suggest in high school what do you
suggest i do in that context to keep
from perpetuating well you know that's
really important you know a lot of
people i suspect many of you if you
think of your own experience i know me
you can remember cases where a teacher
really made a terrific impression on you
i mean most schooling is just trained
training for stupidity and conformity
but every once in a while and that's
institutional too there are reasons for
that but occasionally you know you get a
spark
somebody will challenge your mind you
know make you think encourage you to
think and so on and that's a tremendous
effect you know you just reach all sorts
of people
of course if you do it you're going to
be
you may very well
have problems
you have to tread a narrow line
there are plenty of people who don't
want students to think
they don't they're afraid of the crisis
of democracy you know people start
thinking and you get all these problems
i was quoting at the beginning you know
they won't have humility enough to
submit to a civil rule you know or
they'll start trying to press their
demands in the political arena or
they'll you know have ideas of their own
instead of believing what they're told
and uh privilege and power typically
doesn't want that
so they can
react
and the high school teacher who tries to
get students to think may find the
repression
uh firing and so on i said a lot about
the role of the media in a so-called
democracy
i'm wondering how you see
the role of our educational system what
it's doing right now what forces are
driving
and what constraints are on it and how
should it operate
well
i quoted the trilateral commission
view of the educational system namely
it's a system of indoctrination of the
young
and i think that's correct it's a system
of indoctrination of the young that was
the way the liberal elites regard it and
they're more or less accurate
so the educational system is supposed to
train people to be
obedient conformist
not think too much do you told
stay passive don't cause any crisis of
democracy don't raise any questions and
so on that's basically what the
what the system is about
uh even the fact that the system has a
lot of stupidity in it i think has a
function
you know it means that people are
filtered out for obedience
if you can guarantee lots of stupidity
in the educational system you know like
stupid assignments and things like that
you know that the only people who make
it through
are people like me and like most of you
i guess who are willing to do it no
matter how stupid it is because we want
to go to the next step you know so you
may know that this assignment is idiotic
and the guy up there couldn't think his
way out of a paper bag but you'll do it
anyway
because that's the way you get to the
next class
and you want to make it and so on and so
forth well there are people who don't do
that you know
there are people who say i'm not going
to do it it's too ridiculous you know
those people are called behavioral
problems or
something like that they end up in the
principal's office or in the streets or
selling drugs or whatever and all of
this is a technique for
selection for obedience
and i have i don't know how to prove
this but i have a feeling that when you
go to the elite universities you find
more
obedience and conformity
probably because you're getting the
students who were better able to do it
you know
well all of that is functional that's
the way it works but it and it works
right through graduate school
i mean if you there are by the time you
get to graduate school it's already a
little more varied because some real
contradictions develop in the system the
problem is that you can't have
progress this way
you know now especially in the sciences
and engineering that's a problem
because the corporations need science
and engineering
you know if you don't have innovation
you're really in trouble
so they have to encourage creativity and
independence
because you can't
get anywhere if you just copy what
somebody told you you have to be
challenging things all the time
challenging everything you know
and thinking new thoughts and so on and
there you got a real contradiction uh
it's hard to train people to be creative
and challenging and so on and yet to
ensure that somewhere else in their
lives they're conformist and obedient
never think so you have problems that's
a serious problem in japan incidentally
we think of japan as this tremendous
superpower but that's very misleading
japan for example is very poor in
science for example and they're aware of
it and part of the reason is it's such
as part of it it's part of the same
thing that makes them good workers
obedient workers it's a very obedient
society very deferential and conformist
society and one effect of that is that
you know there are real constraints
against
independent free
thinking and you see it in the sciences
very clearly
uh
the
but it's a problem here too so there are
those contradictions when you get to
graduate school they're beginning to
show up they show up much less in the
ideological subject
because there it doesn't matter so much
if people have you know there isn't
profits aren't made
by historians having original ideas
about the french revolution so they can
have conventional ideas and that means
that the the pressure to try to support
innovation and freedom is much less and
the profession the pressures for
conformity on the other hand are much
greater because in the ideological
subjects it begins to be dangerous if
people think the wrong thoughts it's not
so dangerous if they have no ideas about
physics
so so you get but nevertheless you know
there's you begin to get a little flux
in the system by the time you get to
graduate school and even at lower levels
you find it i mean there's you know
there are teachers who do stimulate
thought
and sometimes they get away with it
and
all the way through
you know if people are learning things
you just you just can't control you
can't make them just regurgitate what
they heard now there's a lot of pressure
to turn the schools into the marine
corps
and there's a lot of support for it for
example there's this best seller
last couple of years by alan bloom
that was all over the supermarket
closing the american mine yeah whichever
you know huge bestseller supermarket
racks which is where i read it and
things like that uh well you take a look
at what he's saying
and there's plenty you know a lot of
enthusiastic accolades for it and so on
uh he was saying that
a couple of us smart guys will decide
what the great thoughts are
and every student will memorize them
and that's education
okay well you know i mean that's a way
to turn people into pure automata i mean
even if they happen to pick the great
thoughts
uh there is no way less
likely to get anybody to think about
those thoughts than to make that the
curriculum that finishes them off no uh
but
and i think that's the purpose really i
mean the purpose is just to impose
authority you know
here's the great thoughts all this other
stuff is rubbish just learn those and
you're okay i'll pick them you memorize
them that's basically the line
now of course that's that's the opposite
of education and that's the way you
study talmud or something like that
but
it's very popular and i think it
reflects the same concern over the
crisis of democracy in fact alan
bloom himself was
extremely the incident that really got
to him was a case in
cornell where he was a professor where
some black students took over one of the
administ one of the buildings
and he was he said that's just like the
nazi you know it's back to the nazis he
has a whole business about the nazis and
so on and so forth well you take a look
at what happened in that he doesn't tell
you what he thought the and he says the
faculty capitulated you know just like
heidegger capitulated to the nazis and
so on
what actually happened if you look back
is that there were real grievances
undoubtedly the students shouldn't have
done what they did and go into the
building with guns and so on but it was
settled very amicably
it was settled amicably amicably nobody
was killed
the grievances were to some extent dealt
with and the net result was better than
it was before but he didn't tell you
what he thought they should have done
but it's sort of implicit i mean i guess
they should have bombed the place or
something like that
but
that's what really set them off and in
general what set many people off was the
you know the the 60s are now described
in the literature as if it was a time
when students were running around
burning libraries and you know
destroying the foundations of
civilization and so on what was actually
going on is they were asking questions
you know they were raising questions
they were
looking into things that people hadn't
looked into before they were not just
obedient and from the point of view of a
lot of the faculty that's equivalent to
burning the buildings you know you can't
do that small distinction you can't make
that
and
this is pressure to turn the schools
back to the days when you didn't have to
worry about those things like
disobedient students asking questions
about things that you didn't tell them
to think about and so on
the last category of the media con game
article in the
progressive by martin lee and norman
solomon is the numbers racket because
any of you have been in demonstrations
have seen this before where the media
will say oh if it's somebody they don't
like then well it'll just be a small
number and the cops will always
underestimate what the organizers
and other people who participated in a
particular thing uh say really happened
uh for instance um
there was a story in new york times that
15 000 jews and palestinians joined
jerusalem peace rally people who saw the
peace rally and who were there said
there had to be at least 35 000 the
organization piece now
said this also
another way they distort they during the
mid 80s the state department always kept
saying and the the media always just
dutifully
repeated their quotes that they're
between uh
2 500 and 3 500 cubans in nicaragua as
military personnel and they eventually
upped that up to 30
3500 to 5 000 cubans
in nicaragua well when rafael del pino
diaz defected to the united states in
1987 he said now there are only been 300
to 400 cubans in nicaragua and that was
the number which the cubans and the
nicaraguans have been saying all along
a more significant way of media
distortion in this numbers racket
category is when they start talking
about
unemployment because the bureau of labor
statistics releases these figures which
you hear repeatedly all the time on the
news
but they really hide
the true extent of unemployment for
instance
not counted are people without jobs who
haven't looked for a job in over a month
because the prospects are discouraging
and they're also they don't
count in it people who retire early they
don't
they
count in the people as being employed
who only worked one day a week now you
can't hardly live on that but
nonetheless that counts as somebody
who's employed but the bureau of labor
statistics actually puts out another
report called the u7 rate which factors
in all these other things we just
mentioned the discouraged employment the
early retirees
so it's a much
much considerably greater
more accurate figure than the one you
get on the regular media so in 1986 when
the media reported the average national
unemployment rate was 6.2 percent
the u7 rate which the journalists
ignored
was
14.3 percent
and that was much
more accurate but of course that would
have everybody all up in the air and
excited and they don't want to do that
in this country we've got to keep the
people cool
so what's the
worth of all the news you get from the
media particularly on television british
journalist named ed harriman says
despite the wonders of communications
technology
the news often seems little more than
folklore
a steady stream of nursery tales for
adults
and that's the end of this alternative
views
i'd like to thank lori lachlan melissa
crowley and michael ferris for their
editing assistance on this program
also paul lakowsky and jim dickerson who
provided the tape with a speech of noam
chomsky from eau claire wisconsin